[موسيقى]
مساء الخير مشاهدي العربيه واهلا بكم الى
التاسعه مع ليلى الاختيار استهلها بابرز
العناوين
[موسيقى]
حديثنا امريكي عن هجوم اوكرانيا مضاد في
الربيع وبولندا توفي بوعود ارسال
المقاتلات الجويه الى كيف
التي يمكن عندها ان يكون هناك لقاء بيني
وبين ارجوك بعد لقائه بوتين الاسد يتحدث
عن اللقاء مع اردوغان قد يكون اليوم او
غدا لكن اذا استوفيت الشروط اولا
ونتطلع الى ان يعزوا هذا الاتفاق من امنه
واستقرار من طبخه الخليج العربي ويدعم
مسيره العمل الاسلاميه المشترك كما تؤكد
بان ينعكس الاتفاق مع ايران ايجابا على
دول المنطقه
يستعينوا بالدستور لتمرين قانون التقاعد
والمعارضه تدعو للانتقام عبر سحب الثقه من
الحكومه
[موسيقى]
نبدا مشاهدينا من الحرب في اوكرانيا حيث
اعلن البنتاجون انه ينصق مع الحلفاء لسحب
مخزوناتهم من الذخيره وارسالها الى
اوكرانيا اضافه الى مفاوضات مع كوريا
الجنوبيه لشراء ذخيره وارسالها لكياف ايضا
ياتي ذلك التزامنا مع ما نشرته ان اداره
الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن تتوقع قيام
اوكرانيا بهجوم مضاد في مايو المقبل
للاستعاده اراضيها مصادر الصحيفه اشارت
ايضا الى ان الهجوم الاوكراني المضاد
سيكون من خلال احتمالين اثنين الاول من
خلال الهجوم جنوبا عبر نهر خرسون الى شبه
جزيره القرم اما الاحتمال الاخر فسيكون من
خلال شن هجوم القوات الاوكرانيه باتجاه
بحر ازوف بهدف قطع الممر المؤدي الى شبه
جزيره القرن
اذا اوكرانيا ليس لديها وقت تضيع تخوف
امريكي من هجوم روسي شرس متوقع باواخر
الربيع في اوكرانيا واشنطن تسابق الوقت
لقلب المصالح لمعركه كيافو لصالحك عبر نقل
الجيش الامريكي لمعداته الى ساحه المعركه
لتدريب القوات الاوكرانيه بوتيره سريعه
طبعا قبل الهجوم الكبير المتوقع ضد روسيا
تقول هنا
بان مئات الدبابات والعربات المدرعه في
طريقها الى اوكرانيا بما في ذلك لاول مره
ثماني مركبات مدرعه يمكنها مد الجسور
والسماح للقوات بعبور الانهار واشنطن لا
تريد فقط كسب معركه الربيع ضد موسكو انما
تعمل على تمكين القوات الاوكرانيه
بالاسلحه والذخيره اللازمه لاستعاده
الاراضي التي خسروها في كامل الشرق
والجنوب في الفتره الماضيه المخاوف
الامريكيه مشاهدينا قابلها بعدما اعلنت
الاخيره ان اوكرانيا على وشك مواجهه احداث
عسكريه خطيره ليست لصالح كياف والظروف
الجويه الراهنه لا تصب في صالح الجيش
الاوكراني لان استخدام معدات عسكريه ثقيله
كما هو معروف على طرقات موحله لن يكون
سهلان وبالتالي هذا الامر سيكون صعبا ايضا
على القوات الروسيه
قال المستشار الالماني انه من المهم جدا
تامين ذخائر بسرعه لاوكرانيا من اجل
التصدي للغزو الروسي داعيا للشركاء
الاوروبيين لايجاد تدابير جديده بهذا
الخصوص
سنستمر مع شركائنا الاوروبيين في ضمان
حصول اوكرانيا على اسلحه ومعدات للصمود
والدفاع عن نفسها من المهم تزويد اوكرانيا
بالذخيره اللازمه بسرعه في المجلس
الاوروبي وجمبا الى جنب مع شركائنا في
الاتحاد الاوروبي سنتفق على المزيد من
الاجراءات لتحقيق امدادات افضل وبشكل
مستمر ونحن مستعدون لفتح مشاريع المشتريات
في المانيا للدول الاعضاء ايضا
قبل ذلك كشف الرئيس البولندي ان بلاده
تعتزم ارسال اربع طائرات مقاتله من طراز
الى اوكرانيا بالاضافه الى طائرات اخرى
بعد الانتهاء من صيانتها
كخطوه الاولى في الايام القليله المقبله
سنرسل اربع طائرات مقاتله من طراز ميج
تسعه وعشرين تعمل بكامل طاقتها الى
اوكرانيا اما الطائرات الاخرى التي تخضع
حاليا للصيانه والعمل سننجح في ارسالها
الى اوكرانيا لاحقا
للحديث اكثر مشاهدينا عن الدعم الامريكي
لكياف بهذه الحرب ستنضم اليه بالاستوديو
الزميله ناديه البلبيسي مديره مكتب
العربيه في واشنطن اهلا وسهلا بك ناديه
ناديه يعني اذا اختصرنا الاستراتيجيه
الامريكيه بالسنه الثانيه من الحرب دعم
اكياس بالاسلحه وطبعا استعاده اكبر قدر
ممكن من الاراضي وقلب موازين القوى مع
المعركه الجديده كيف تتبلور هذه النقاط
الثلاثه اولا بالخط العريض لوزير الخارجيه
عفوا وزير الدفاع
الذي قال بانه لا يوجد لدينا وقت لنضيعه
باي معنى بمعنى بانه الان هناك معركه
حقيقيه في الربيع وهم يعتقدون بانه على
اوكرانيا الان ان تحصل على تدريب للقوات
الاوكرانيه على صيانه للقطعه الغيار وعلى
اسلحه وذخيره نوعيه يمكن ان تعكس مجرى
المعركه كما تعرفين ايضا هناك تخوف بانه
عندما نبدا الفصل الربيع تبدا الثلوج
بالذوبان وبالتالي حتى الدبابات لا تستطيع
ان تستخدمها في مناطق فيها وحل كثيره مثل
لا تستطيع ان تتقدم ومن هنا التركيز
الامريكي على كيف يمكن انقاذ هذه المعركه
في وقت حساس من خلال كل هذه الاسلحه وكما
ذكرتي ليس فقط من الولايات المتحده لكن من
اهم حليف برز في هذه الحرب وهي بولندا
التي قالت بانها سترسل اربع طائرات من
طائرات ميج 28 وهي طائرات سوفيتيه الصنع
كما تعرف وبالتالي سهل جدا استخدامها على
عكس الطلب الاوكراني بانها تريد طائرات اف
16 الامريكيه الدعم البولندي بالطائرات هل
ممكن ان يسرع الدعم الامريكي بالطائرات ام
ان الموضوعين منفصلين تماما يمكن ان يسرع
لكن هناك تخوف امريكي بالنسبه لي الطائرات
اف 16 لانه هذه طائرات متطوره جدا
تخشى بانها لن تستطيع القوات الاوكر
يعني اذا تحدثنا عن مفاوضات يجب ان يكون
هناك معركه عسكريه يتم لاحد الطرفين ان
يكسبها او على الاقل على الاقل يدرك بانه
لن يكسبها وبالتالي يجبر على التفاوض ومن
هنا اعتقد بان الحلفاء سواء كانوا بقياده
الولايات المتحده تريد بالفعل ان يكون
هناك سلاح نوعي وليس فقط سلاح نوعي لكن
حديث وانت تغطينا الحرب منذ فتره تراقبين
كل خبر يوميا بانه لا يوجد هناك اسلحه
كافيه نتحدث عن ذخيره ابدا 155 هذا طلب
اوكراني يومي تقريبا كل مسؤول اوكرانيا
يقول بحاجه الى اسلحه اكثر حتى المسؤولين
الاوكرانيين يتذمرون من تاخير دفعات
السلاح ومن عدم انتظام اعطائهم هذه الدفعه
هل ممكن ان يحصل ايضا هناك تغيير بالمرحله
المقبله بما اننا نتحدث عن مرحله جديده
بهذه الحرب الولايات المتحده ستبحث عن
مخزون لهذه الاسلحه في اماكن اخرى وخصوصا
في اوروبا الشرقيه من خلال حلفائها لكن
بالنسبه للصناعات الاسلحه في الولايات
المتحده ستستغرق وقتا يعني دبابات ابرمز
التي تحدث عنها بحاجه الى وقت طويل
لتصنيعها وحتى ارسالها وبالتالي هي تبحث
عن بدائل هذه البدائل موجوده على حدود
اوكرانيا وبالتحديد بولندا التي اصبحت
الدوله المحوريه في هذه الحرب ومن هنا اتى
الخبر الذي ذكرناه قبل قليل عن استخدام
المخزونات الامريكيه لدى دول حلف الناتو
هل هذه المخزونات كافيه بالمرحله المقبله
في حرب مثل هذه لا شيء يكفي اكيد لكن
الولايات المتحده تضع خطه استراتيجيه على
المدى المتوسط وعلى المدى القريب وعلى
المدى البعيد المدى الحاليه تريد ان تنقذ
هذه الحرب لصالح اوكرانيا بمعنى هي تعتمد
على قوه وشراسه الجنود الاوكرانيين الذين
اثبتوا بالفعل بانهم يحاربون من اجل
بقائهم واستعاده سيادتهم من وجهه النظر
الامريكيه لكن هم بحاجه لدعم وهذا الدعم
قوي جدا يجب ان ياتي من خلال كل هذه
الاسلحه لاستعاده بعض هذه الاراضي وخصوصا
المخمود وكما تعرفين لا يحبون فقط الجيش
الروسي لكن ايضا قوات
وقاديره ايضا ناديه بالعوده الى داخل
الامريكي هناك اعتراض داخل مجلس النواب
على موضوع الدعم بالاسلحه هذا هذا
الاعتراض هل ممكن ان يعرقل اي شيء من
الخطط التي اعلنتها واشنطن بالمرحله
الماضيه لا لن يعرقل لانه الاعتراض هو لا
يتجاوز 20% في داخل الحزب الجمهوري وفي
مجلس النواب من ماذا نبع بانه لا يجب ان
نعطي اوكرانيا شيك على بياض بان سقف الدين
الامريكي مرتفع جدا لدينا تضخم الانعكاسات
ولدينا مشاكل اقتصاديه كبيره وبالتالي يجب
ان تصرف هذه الاموال في الدخل الامريكي هي
رساله داخليه ليست اكثر لكن على المنظور
الاكبر وهناك طبعا بعد استراتيجي بنا هذه
معركه وجوديه من وجهه النظر الغرب بقياده
الولايات المتحده وخصوصا الصقور في الحزب
الجمهوري في العاده هم يدافعون ضد اي حرب
يمكن ان تمس سياده دوله ديمق او دوله
قريبه من حلف شمال الاطلسي وضد روسيا
وبالتالي سيكون الدعم سيستمر الاصوات لا
تزال يعني نوعا ما لم تصل الى مرحله
الاعتراض الذي سيؤثر على اتخاذ قرارات
اننا الان نتحدث عن تغيير موازين القوى
العالميه وليس فقط تهديد يعني الامن
القومي والوجود الامريكي ناديه شكرا لك
ناديه البلبيسي مديره مكتب العربيه في
واشنطن على وجودك معنا وعلى هذه المعطيات
شكرا لك
نبقى مشاهدينا في الحرب الاوكرانيه لكن
ميدانيا اذا افاد رئيس السلطه المواليه
لروسيا في دونياس بعدم وجود اي مؤشرات على
انسحاب قريب للقوات الاوكرانيه في البخموت
مشيرا الى ان المعارك في المدينه الواقعه
شرق اوكرانيا لا تزال صعبه ومعقده للغايه
كما اشار الى ان الجيش الروسي بدا هجوما
موسعا من محاور عده على مدينه افديفيكا
بدونياسك للسيطره عليها
الى ذلك نقل موقع انسايدر عن تقارير روسيه
محليه ان وزاره الدفاع الروسيه تخطط
لتجنيد 400 الف من المتطوعين سيتعاقدون
معهم لثلاث سنوات مع نهايه هذا العام
400 الف جندي روسي اضافي الى جبهات القتال
نهايه هذا العام تعبئه جديده تخطط لها
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه منذ الاول من المقبل
وحمله تجنيد قوامها متطوعون تسعى الى
تعزيز القوه البشريه في الجيش الروسي
بنسبه 50% وفقا لتقارير محليه
التقارير افادت بان وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
ابلغت رؤساء الاقاليم بقرار التعبئه وبعدد
المجندين الذين يتعين عليهم تجهيزهم مع
نهايه العام
كما شوهد مسؤولون عسكريون في المناطق
القريبه من الحدود مع اوكرانيا يوزعون
مذكرات استدعاء على السكان طالبوهم بتحديث
بياناتهم بمكاتب التجنيد وفقا لبي بي بي
سي روسيا
وسائل اعلام روسيا اخرى ذكرت ان الجيش
الروسي ينتظر من المجندين الجدد ان يكونوا
ذوي قدره على تشغيل المدرعات والمدفعيه
خاصه بعد تقارير السابقه اشارت الى ان
الذين تلقوا تدريبا محدودا قتلوا بشكل
جماعي وفي حاله تنفيذ هذه التعبئه تكون
الاخيره تناقضت مع تصريح سابق لوزير
الدفاع الروسي فبراير الماضي نف فيه اي
خطط لتعبئه الذاكره
واذكر ان موسكو في سبتمبر الماضي اعلنت عن
تعبئه جزئيه ل 300 الف من جنود الاحتياط
[موسيقى]
وفي جديد ازمه المسيره الامريكيه قال
الكريم ان الجيش الروسي سيعمل على انتشال
حطام المسيره من قاع البحر الاسود اذا
اعتبر ذلك ضروريا للامن القومي من جهات
اخرى عربه الكريم عن اسفه لمساعي السويد
وفنلندا للانضمام الى حلف الناتو مشددا
على ان روسيا لم ولن تكن تشكل تهديدا
للبلدين
وفيما نشرت القوات الامريكيه مقطعا مصورا
لعمليه اسقاط مسيراتها من قبل القوات
الروسيه فوق البحر الاسود فلنتابع
[موسيقى]
اكد رئيس الوفد الروسي في محادثات فيينا
بشان الامن العسكري والحد من التسلح ان
الغرب تجاهل لفتره طويله بشكل واضح
مقترحات روسيا لاتخاذ تدابير لمنع الحوادث
الخطيره بما في ذلك في الجو وكانت هذه
الخطوات ضروريه لمنع سقوط المسيره
الامريكيه في البحر الاسود لو اتخذت
نشر فريق تحقيق من الامم المتحده تقريرا
قال انه تم نقل اطفال اوكرانيين الى
المناطق الخاضعه لسيطره موسكو في اوكرانيا
والى روسيا وهذا النقل يشكل جريمه حرب
واضاف المحققون في تقريرهم ان مهاجمه
روسيا البنيه التحتيه للطاقه الاوكرانيه
واستخدام التعذيب قد يشكل جرائم ضد
الانسانيه
في اول خطاب رئيسي يلقيها امام اقطاب
الاعمال منذ بدء العمليات العسكريه في
اوكرانيا قال رئيس روسيا فلاديمير بوتين
ان بلاده تواجه حرب عقوبات مؤكدا ان موسكو
تمكنت من تعويض اغلاق الاسواق الغربيه
امامها واضاف بوتين ان روسيا تعيد توجيه
دفه اقتصادها بسرعه نحو الدول التي لم
تستهدفها بالعقوبات واعتبر الرئيس الروسي
ان منطقه اليورو تحاول اقناع الجميع
بالانهيار الوشيك للاقتصاد الروسي والتضخم
المرتفع الا ان روسيا تدرك ان تلك مجرد
شائعات مبالغ فيها
سياسيا مشاهدينا شجع وزير خارجيه الصين
نظيره الاوكراني ديميتروكوليبا على
الاستمرار في محادثات السلام مع موسكو
وزير الخارجيه الصينيه عبر عن مخاوف الصين
من تصاعد الازمه وشدد على ضروره استكمال
المحادثات في اقرب وقت والاتجاه نحو تسويه
السياسيه
[موسيقى]
في حاله توفيت شروط فلا موعد محدد للقاء
اردوغان قد يكون اليوم او غدا يقول هنا
رئيس النظام السوري بشار الاسد وسط تكثيف
روسيا الجهود لتجاوز عراقيل تعترض مسار
تطبيع العلاقات بين كل من سوريا وتركيا
الاجتماع الرباعي لنواب وزراء خارجيه كل
من روسيا وايران وتركيا وسوريا تم ارجائه
من دون تحديد موعد جديد بعدما اصر رئيس
النظام السوري بشار الاسد على شروطه واول
هذه الشروط خروج القوات التركيه من سوريا
لعقد اي لقاء مع نظيره التركي اردوغان
كلام الاسد جاء بعد لقائه الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين الساعي لاصلاح العلاقات
بين دمشق وانقره المنقطعه منذ اندلاع
الحرب في سوريا عام 2011 ومن اجل عقد قمه
بين الرئاسه التركيه والسوريه يجب اولا
عقد عده اجتماعات تحضيريه وهذه العمليه
جاريه تقول هنا موسكو طبعا بعدما تحدث
اردوغان اكثر من مره عن احتمال عقد لقاء
مع الاسد واول مؤشر على تقارب محتمل بين
كل من انقره ودمشق عقد وزيره الدفاع
السوري والتركي محادثات في موسكو في
ديسمبر بحضور نظرهما الروسي في اعلى مستوى
من المحادثات بين الجانبين منذ اندلاع
الحرب السوريه قبل اكثر من عقد
[موسيقى]
للحديث اكثر مشاهدينا عن هذا الاتفاق وهذا
اللقاء ينضم الينا من اسطنبول جواد جوك
المحلل السياسي استاذ جواد يعني عندما
يعلن الاسد بان لا لقاء قبل انسحاب كامل
للقوات التركيه هو يعلم بان هذا الشرط غير
منطقي في المرحله الحاليه هل هو يعني
يحاول تعليه سقف المطالب قبل الذهاب الى
حوار حول مطالب اخرى
[موسيقى]
وهو مكافحه للارهاب وبالتالي هذا الموضوع
حتى مع المعارضه يعني من المسلمات في
الداخل هذه الرساله كيف يمكن ان يتعاطى
معها الكل
بالنتيجه يعني هناك نقاط مشتركه بين تركيا
وسوريا حول مثلا ما يجري في الشرقي الفرات
يعني ضروره مواجهه قوات قصه في شرقي
الفرات ممكن ان يبداون الجانبين السوري
والتركي من العمليات المشتركه السياسيه
والعسكريه وهذا طبعا سيسبب تقارب الكردي
مع حكومه دمشق وغير ذلك برعايه الروسيه
هذه الرسائل انه ممكن ان تكون هناك تعاون
مشترك بالنتيجه قضيه اللاجئين اهم خطيه في
تركيا لابد ان يكون التنسيق مع حكومه دمشق
الكل يعرف ذلك فيؤكد حكومه او المعارضه
ولهذا السبب من الضروري ان يبداون بخطوات
عمليه مشتركه بين الجانبين ممكن ان يبداوا
من الشرقي الفرات حتى يصلون الى ما يجري
لادلب يعني موضوع التعاون بين انا بالتركي
والروسي بموضوع قصد هو مطروح منذ فتره
وليس بالجديد ولكن اليوم السوري على قناعه
بان ما يريده اردوغان هو ورقه رابحه في
الانتخابات وفي الحمله الانتخابيه هناك
وهو لا يريد اعطاء له يعني ببلاش اذا صح
التعبير هذا الاء يعني يسقط نظريه التعاون
الان
طبعا يعني لهذه النظريه ايضا يعني ممكن ان
يكون ذلك راينا لانه راينا في العلاقات
التركيه المصريه
مع الظروف المناسبه الحكومه التركيه لم
تختو الخطوات عمليه تجاه النصر وقضايا
قضيه عوده العلاقات مع مصر اسهل بكثير من
عوده العلاقات مع سوريا لكن بسبب اننا
راينا ان الحكومه التركيه اذ كان بطيئا
جدا في تاسيس العلاقات مع مصر نفس
السيناريو الان بالنسبه الى سوريا ولهذا
سبب لا ثقه لسياسه الحكومه التركيه
الحاليه في هذه الاشياء الراعي الاساسي
لهذا التقارب هي روسيا الى اي مدى ممكن ان
تضغط روسيا اليوم على الجانبين التركي
والسوري وتنتزع يعني تنازلات من الطرفين
خصوصا ان التقارب بين الطرفين هي مصلحه
روسيه
بالنتيجه في
كل هذه هذا التصفير
تركيا كلما تعاونت مع الجانب الروسي وقام
باقامه بالتنسيق مع الجانب الروسي اخذت
نتائج ملموسه بالخطوات العمليه بخلاف
الجانب الامريكي ولهذا السبب بشكل عملي
تركيا الان حليف مع الجانب الروسي في ساحه
السوريه بصراحه ولهذا سبب تركيا تثق جدا
الى رعايه الروسيه دون ايران بالنتيجه
هناك منافسه ايرانيه التركيه دائما موجوده
لكن بالنسبه الى روسيا تركيا تثق ايضا من
نتيجه كلمه الاخيره في ساحه سوريا مع
الجانب الروسي ولهذا السبب انا اظن انه ما
دام ما دام الرعايه الروسيه مستمره بهذا
الشكل تركيا لابد ان تصل بالنتيجه امن
القومي التركي مرتبطه في في التعاظم مع
الجانب السوري بالرعايه الروسيه شكرا لك
استاذ جواد جوكا المحل السياسي حدثتنا من
اسطنبول
مسؤول في البانتاجون قال بان واشنطن تشهد
سلوكا غير احترافي لطيران الروسي في سوريا
منذ بدايه الشهر الحالي حيث ياتي التصريح
عقب اسقاط مسيره امريكيه فوق البحر الاسود
اسرع اعتراضها من قبل مقاتلات روسيه
التاسعه مستمره وفيها بعد قليل
الجيش الليبي يعثر على اليورانيوم المفقود
من احد المستودعات بالقرب من الحدود
التشاديه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد اكد وزير الخارجيه
السعوديه الامير فيصل بن فرحان ان المملكه
تدعم وحل الخلافات عبر الحوار ومن هذا
المنطلق توصلت الى اتفاقيه مع ايران بعد
جلسات في مسقط بغداد وبكين معربا في كلمه
خلال افتتاح المجلس الوزاري لدول التعاون
الاسلاميه عن تطلعه الى ان تنعكس
الاتفاقيه ايجابا على المنطقه
ان المملكه العربيه السعوديه تؤمن باهميه
ما يجمعنا من روابط الدين والجوار وتبسط
يدها دوما للحوار يحل الخلافات بالطرق
السلميه ومن هذا المنطلق اجرت لاكثر من
عامين عده جولات للحوار على الشقاء في
ايران في كل من بغداد واسقط ثم مؤخرا في
بكين وقد تكلت هذه المباحثات بالاتفاق على
عادات الاعاده العلاقات الدبلوماسيه بين
البلدين على اساس احترام المبادئ ومقاصد
ميثاق المتحده ومنظمه التعاون الاسلامي
سياده الدول وعدم التدخلة وحسن الجوار وحل
الخلافات حوار ونتطلع الى ان يعزز هذا
الاتفاق من امننا واستقرار منطقه الخليج
العربي ويدعم مسيره العمل الاسلاميه
المشترك
وفيما يتعلق بالقضيه الفلسطينيه اكد وزير
الخارجيه السعوديه على حق الفلسطينيين في
دوله مستقله على حدود العام 67 مدينا في
الوقت نفسه انتهاكات قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيليه في حق الشعب الفلسطيني
تؤكد المملكه موقفها الداعم للاسراع في
ايجاد الحل العابد وشامل للقضيه
الفلسطينيه وفق قرارات الشرعيه الدوليه
ومبادره السلام العربيه
واقامه دوله فلسطين مستقله على حدود عام
وعاصمتها القدس الشرقيه والمملكه كانت ولا
زالت تدعم الشعب الفلسطيني لاستعاده حقوقه
المشروعه
والمجتمع الدولي للقيام بدوره في وضع حد
الانتهاكات قوات الاعتداء الاسرائيليه
تجاه الشعب الفلسطيني وتقويض فرص احياء
عمليه السلام
هذا وشدد وزير الخارجيه السعوديه على دعم
المملكه المتواصل للسلام في اليمن ولكل
الجهود الداعيه لوقف اطلاق النار بشكل
دائم
ان المملكه تجدد دعمها للسلام في اليمن
ولجهود المبعوث الامني الى اليمن الراميه
الى التوصل لوقف كامل ودائم لاطلاق النار
وبدء العمليه السياسيه بين الحكومه
اليمنيه والحوثيين وتؤكد على دعم مجلس
القياده الرئاسي اليمني لتمكينه من تنفيذ
سياسات ومبادرات فعاله من شانها تحقيق
الامن والاستقرار في الجمهوريه اليمنيه
وانهاء الازمه
الى ذلك افادت صحيفه بموافقه ايران على
وقف تصليح الحوثيين في اطار الاتفاق على
استئناف العلاقات مع السعوديه كما اشارت
الصحيفه ايضا الى ان نهج ايران حيال
الصراع في اليمن سيكون اختبارا حقيقيا
لنواياها بعد عوده العلاقات مع الرياض وان
هذه الاتفاقيه ستعطي دفعه لتوصل الى صفقه
لانهاء النزاع في اليمن في وقت قريب
الى ذلك اكد مصدر سعودي للعربيه ان
الاتفاقيه الامنيه واتفاقيه التعاون
المتعدده المجالات التي تم الاتفاق على
تفعيلها مع ايران توضح اهميه ما سيترتب
على تبادل الثقه والاحترام من فرص ايجابيه
تنعكس لفائده الشعبين وجميع شعوب المنطقه
كما شدد على ان الالتزام باحترام السياده
وعدم التدخل في الشؤون الداخليه وحل
الخلافات بالطرق السلميه يشمل جميع الدول
العربيه والاسلاميه وعبر عن امله في ان
ينعكس هذا ايجابا على كل الملفات والازمات
في المنطقه
استقبل رئيس دوله الامارات الشيخ محمد بن
زايد امين المجلس الاعلى للامن القومي
الايراني علي شامخاني وافادت وكاله
الانباء الاماراتيه انه جاره خلال اللقاء
بحث العلاقات الثنائيه وسبل مد جسور
التعاون بين البلدين في مختلف المجالات
بما يحقق المصالح المشتركه
هذا وقال مساعد وزير الخارجيه الايرانيه
علي باقر ان بلاده ستوفد سفيرا لها الى
الامارات قريبا واضاف باقه في تصريحات
لوكاله الانباء الايرانيه ان الاجراءات
اللازمه لافاد السفير الى ابوظبي دخلت حيز
التنفيذ بعد اعاده الامارات سفيرها الى
ايران اعتبر مساعد وزير الخارجيه ان
العلاقات بين ايران والامارات لم تنقطع
ابدا وانما شهد التراجعا في المستوى
[موسيقى]
كشف الجيش الليبي ان قوه تابعه له عثرت
على الكميه المفقوده من اليورانيوم بالقرب
من الحدود التشاديه وحمل بيان الجيش
الطاقه الدوليه الحادثه مشيرا الى ان
الوكاله تكفلت بكافه المصاريف والمعدات
اللازمه لفرق الحراسه لكنها لم تفي بتلك
التعهدات الامر الذي جعل فرق الحراسه تقف
على مسافه بعيده لحمايتها من الاشعه
[موسيقى]
وبالعوده مشاهدينا الى قصه الاختفاء
مفتشوا الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه
كانوا قد اكتشفوا خلال عمليه تفتيش اختفاء
عشره براميل تحتوي على ما يقارب
2.5 طن من اليورانيوم الطبيعي هذه المواد
كانت ليبيا قد ابلغت عنها باعتبارها مخزنه
قبل اختفائها احد المواقع المعلنه لاختفاء
اليورانيوم منها كانت قرب مطار سبها اي
على بعد حوالي 660 كيلو مترا جنوب شرق
العاصمه الليبيه طرابلس حيث قامت ليبيا
تحت حكم معمر القذافي بتخزين الاف
البراميل مما يسمى يورانيوم الكعكه
الصفراء في حين ازال المفتشون اخر
اليورانيوم المخصب بليبيا عام 2009 ظلت
الكعكه الصفراء موجوده في مكانها وكان
اختفاء هذه الكميه الكبيره من اليورانيوم
الطبيعي اثارت مخاوف تتعلق بالسلامه
وانتشار الاسلحه لماذا لان كل طن من
اليورانيوم الطبيعي في حال فرضيه وقوعها
بيد جهه لديها الوسائل والموارد
والتكنولوجيا كاجهزه الطرد المركزيه
يمكنها تحويله الى
خمسه.6 كيلو جرامات من المواد المستخدمه
في صنع الاسلحه لكن تلك المخاوف تبددت
لاحقا طبعا بعد عثور الجيش على الكميه
وتجدر الاشاره هنا ايضا الى انه لا يمكن
استخدام اليورانيوم الطبيعيه على الفور
لانتاج الطاقه او وقود القنابل لان عمليه
التخصيم تتطلب اعاده تحويل المعدن الى غاز
ثم يتم تدويره لاحقا في اجهزه الطرد
المركزي للوصول الى المستويات المطلوبه
[موسيقى]
الى مصر حيث اعربت وزاره الخارجيه
الاثيوبيه في بيان عن رفضها لتصريحات وزير
الخارجيه المصريه سامح شكري بشان ملف سد
النهضه والذي قال فيه بان كل الخيارات
مفتوحه واضافت الخارجيه الاثيوبيه ان الحل
الوديه لملف سد النهضه مع مصر والسودان
ممكن اذا توافرت حسن النيه في المفاوضات
ومن جهته اكد مساعد وزير الخارجيه المصري
للشؤون الافريقيه محمد البدري ان قضيه سد
النهضه تمثل اولويه وجوديه تمس حياه الشعب
المصري باكمله
[موسيقى]
الى لبنان وبقائمه تضم 100 سؤال وعلى مدى
ثلاثه ايام انتهت اول جلسه استجواب لرياض
سلامه حاكم مصرف لبنان بحضور القضاء
الاوروبي جلسه وصفت بالهادئه واستمرت لست
ساعات وبعد انتهاء الجلسه الاولى حدد
القاضي شربل ابو سمره صباح الجمعه موعدا
جديدا لمثول سلامه امام الوفود القضائيه
الاوروبيه بتهم تبييض الاموال والاثراء
غير المشروع
والتفاصيل في تقرير التالي
[موسيقى]
بينما انتظر الاعلاميون على مدخل قصر
العدل اصول حاكم مصر في لبنان الرياض
سلامه الذي حضر مكرها لجلسه استجواب حول
اتهامات طالته دخل سلام من باب خلفي بعيدا
عن عدسات كانت حاضره لرسبه
في الداخل وفد اوروبي متسلح بمئه سؤال
رفعها قادم لبناني حفاظا على سياده الدوله
اجاب سلامي على ما طرح من اسئله في جلسه
وصفتها مصادر بالهادئه كان وصلها سلامي
بالصحبه محاميه الفرنسي نحن بانتظار
انتهاء تحيه الاوروبي بالموضوع وبعد عوده
القضاه الاوروبيين الى بلادهم بنشوف شو هو
القرار لحيت هل هيعتبر انه في جرم على
رياض سلامه شو هو هذا الجرم حجم الجرم شو
هو وهل يتم اتخاذ اجراءات بحقه وتبليغ
الانتربول
واخيرا حضر سلمه اول مسؤول رفيع المستوى
يخضع للاستجواب في بلد لطالما تفلت مسؤوله
من العقاب ومرت جرائمه الماليه والجنائيه
من دون محاسبه ومثول سلام اليوم وان كان
كشاهد هو مشهد غريب على اللبنانيين
اعتقد اللعبه وصلت الى نقطه لا رجوع فيها
رياض سلامه لا تستطيع السلطه
المنظومه ان تحميه
لان القضاء الاجنبي وضع يده ايضا على
القضيه لو تركت للقضاء المحلي
لامكن رياض سلامه ان يبقى في منصبه وان
يتابع سياسته الماليه وان يستمر في خدمه
من يحميه من اعضاء السلطه
يفضل سلامي انهاء جلساته على عجل على ان
تستكمل لاحقا مع شقيقه رجا ومساعدته مريم
الحويج غنوه يتيم العربيه
[موسيقى]
وباللجوء الى الدستور وكما كان متوقعا قرر
الرئيس الفرنسي مانيويل قرر تمرير مشروع
قانون رفع سن التقاعد دون موافقه البرلمان
الذي شهد اعتراضا كبيرا على القانون
ماكرون برر الاستعانه بالماده
49.3 من الدستور تمرير القانون تجنبا لما
وصفها بالمخاطر الماليه والاقتصاديه
الكبيره جدا على فرنسا القرار اتخذ
مشاهدينا بعد اجتماع ثاني عقد قبل ساعات
في الاليزي بين كل من ماكرون ورئيسه
الحكومه اليزابيث بالاضافه الى عدد من
الوزراء المعنيين فلنتابع
لا يمكننا المخاطره بمستقبل معاشاتنا
التقاعديه ان هذا الاصلاح ضروري ولانني
متمسكه بنموذجنا الاجتماعي ولانني اؤمن
بالديمقراطيه البرلمانيه فان الاصلاح بنص
البرلمان ثمره حل وسط بين المجلسين وانا
مستعده لتحمل المسؤوليه
لكن هذا لن يمر لن يمر طبعا مرور الكرام
وفق ما هددت به احزاب اقصى اليمين
الفرنسيه التي دعت عبر مارينلو بان الى
سحب الثقه من الحكومه انتقاما من تمرير
القانون كما دعت لبان برفقه بقيه احزاب
اليمين الى تظاهرات واضرابات كبيره حتى
تحقيق كل المطالب التي تتمثل بسحب القانون
او سحب الثقه القانون الجديد يقضي برفع سن
التقاعد من 62 عاما الى 64 عاما في وقت
تواجه في فرنسا طبعا ازمات متصاعده بسبب
ارتفاع نسبه الشيخوخه في البلاد
[موسيقى]
لنقل الصوره من فرنسا بعد تمرير هذا
القانون ينضم الينا فادي دهوك مراسل
العربيه فادي حاله الاعتراض الشعبيه من
هناك كيف هي الان بعد تمرير هذا القانون
مساء الخير ليال بعد تمرير هذا القانون في
مجلس النواب من دون التصويت هناك من دون
تصويت النواب خرج التظاهرات عفويه الان
هناك تظاهره امام مجلس النواب في ساحه
الكونكورد تقريبا هناك 6000 متظاهر حتى
الان وهناك اشخاص ما زالوا ينضمون الى هذه
التظاهره ايضا خرج التظاهرات في مدينه
مارسيليا جنوب البلاد هذه حتى الان خريطه
التظاهرات لكن يتوقع في الايام القليله
المقبله ان تعم التظاهرات معظم المدن
الفرنسيه وان تكون الجوله المقبله من
الاحتجاج اضخم بكثير مما كانت عليه في
السابق لان النقابات تحضر لتحركات تقول
انها ستكون منظمه اكثر التقينا مع احدى
المسؤلات في النقابات العمال قالت انهم
يخططون لان يقومون بتحركات شل اقتصاد
البلاد حتى يجبر الحكومه على سحب هذا
القانون كما ذكرتي ان حزب اقصى اليمين
بزعامه مارين لوبين قام او قال انه سيقوم
بطرح مذكره الثقه عن الحكومه ايضا باليسار
سوف تقوم بطرح هذه المذكره هذا الامر
اعلنه الزعيم اليسار
الذي قال خلال بعد الجلسه ان قوه ستقوم
بطرح هذه المذكره وايضا الاحتجاجات لان
هذا المشروع
او نص القرار الذي تم التصويت عليه او تم
اقراره من دون التصويت عليه من قبل النواب
هو نص غير مشروع اي لم ياخذ موافقه
البرلمان وايضا لا يوافق عليهم معظم
الفرنسيين كما تظهر استطلاعات الراي
التحركات المقبله ستكون كبيره الرئيس
الفرنسي خطر بهذه الخطوه وكان هناك
تحذيرات من قبل نقابات العمال بان الرد
سيكون عنيفا جدا في الشارع والايام
المقبله ستثبت صحه هذه التهديدات من عدمها
فادي يعني هل ممكن ان نشهد جيلي جون جديده
مفتوحه وكيف هو التنسيق بين الاحزاب
المعارضه ان كان اليمين واليسار
بالاسابيع والايام المقبله للرد على هذا
التعديل او هذا الاجتهاد القانوني
حتى الان لا يوجد معلومات عن تنسيق بين
قوى اليسار واحزاب اقصى اليمين لكن على
الاقل احزاب اليسار كلها مجتمعه هناك خمسه
احزاب على الاقل متحده فيما بينها وهي
التي تدعم الاحتجاجات مع النقابات عندما
سالت المسؤوله في احدى النقابات قالت ان
شكل الاحتجاج او التصعيد الذي يقومون به
سوف يكون عبر زياده حجم الاضرابات انضمام
قطاعات جديده الى حركه الاضراب وايضا
تنسيق مع حركه السترات الصفر بالاضافه الى
انهم باتوا يعولون على حراك الطلاب تحرك
الطلاب هو حساس جدا في فرنسا وله قوه
تاريخيه وذكريات كثيره خصوصا مع الجنرال
دو غول الذي نجح هذا التحرك الطلابي
بتغيير الحياه السياسيه في فرنسا ولي ذراع
الجنرال حقيقه لذلك التحركات المقبله
ستكون ضخمه ستكون كبيره الاضرابات سوف
تبدا في اقرب موعد عندما يتم التنسيق لها
بعد اجتماع مقرر للنقبات لكي يعلنوا عن
تحركاتهم بشكل رسمي في الايام المقبله
لك
ثم
يعني هناك تدابير امنيه بدات تكون مشدده
اكثر هل هناك اي اشتباكات بين المتظاهرين
وقوى القوى الامنيه
[موسيقى]
الان المتظاهرون يحاولون الابتعاد من هذه
النقطه لان الشرطه تطلب منهم الخروج هم
يهتفون كل الناس تكره الشرطه طبعا هذه
التظاهرات التي خرجت اليوم هي غير مرخصه
هي خرجت بشكل عفوي وكما ترون في الشاشه
هناك حاجه امني ضخم جدا في محيط ساحه
الكونكورد وايضا في معظم المداخل التي
تؤدي الى قصر الرئاسه الفرنسيه هو ليس
ببعيد من هنا هناك حشد امني كثيف جدا
وهناك تعزيزات اتصل باستمرار الى هذه
المنطقه تحسبا لحدوث اعمال العنف كانت قد
حذرت منها النقابات شكرا لك فادي دهوك
مراسل العربيه حدثنا من باريس
مشاهدينا التاسعه مستمره وفيها بعد قليل
بعد اربعين يوما من الزلزال استئناف
الدراسه في الشمال السوري ما يزال امرا
بعيد المنال
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد الى باكستان حيث امرت
محكمه عليا باكستانيه الشرطه بتاجيل القبض
على رئيس الوزراء السابق عمران خان ليوم
اخر سعيا لتهدئه التوترات بعد الشباكات
اندلعت هذا الاسبوع عندما حاولت الشرطه
اعتقاله وكما طالبت محكمه لاهور العليا من
فريق عمران خان القانوني اجراء محادثات مع
الشرطه لحل المشكله ما اثار الامر الصادر
واثار ايضا الامر الصادر موجه ارتياح بين
انصار خان الذين عملوا على منع الشرطه من
الوصول الى منزل خان
بعاصمه اقليم البنجاب طبعا ولكن رغم ذلك
لم تنسحب قوات الشرطه والقوات شبه
العسكريه المنتشره هناك لتنفيذ امر
الاعتقاد
الان في الطريق الرئيسيه المجاور لمنزل
رئيس الوزراء الباكستاني عمران خان كما
ترون الحياه عادت الى طبيعتها في هذا
المكان لكن باستثناء هذا الزحام
اقف الان امام بعض الخيام التي اقامها
حزبا نصاب زعامه عمران خان لاستقبال
انصاره الذين جاءوا هنا للتعبير عن موقفهم
وتضامنهم مع رئيس الوزراء السابق كما ترون
هنا يتواجد هنا مختلف شرائح المجتمع
الباكستاني الذين جاؤوا هنا للتعبير عن
تضامنهم مع رئيس وزراء السابق
هذه هي البوابه الرئيسيه لمنزل رئيس
الوزراء الباكستاني السابق عمران خان هنا
يحتشد العشرات من انصاره على مدار الساعه
هنا تاتي عدد من المجموعات من مختلف
المناطق الباكستانيه للتعبير عن تضامنها
مرددين هتافات مؤيده لعمران خان ومناوية
للحكومه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
هذه خيمه الاعتصام الرئيسيه لانصار رئيس
الوزراء السابق عمران خان بعض المعاصمين
جاؤوا من مناطق مختلفه وبعضهم يمكث هنا
منذ عده ايام دعما لرئيس الوزراء السابق
وتحسبا لاي اجراءات قد تقوم بها الشرطه
لاعتقال زعيمهم
[موسيقى]
وكما ترون يحمل العديد من انصار رئيس
الوزراء الباكستاني السابق عمران خان
الهرواتي والعصي التي يقولون انها للدفاع
عن النفس ضد قمع الشرطه وبالرغم من ان
الاوضاع قد تبدو هادئه فان هذا الهدوء
ربما هو الذي يسبق العاصفه عبد الرحمن
المزيني العربيه لاهور
يبقى معنا مشاهدينا عبد الرحمن المزيني
مراسل العربيه من لاهون عبد الرحمن يعني
عمران خان كان قد اعلن انه سيمثل السبت
امام القضاء مقابل اصرار السلطات على يعني
القاء القبض عليه كيف هي الصوره من هناك
ما الذي سيحصل غدا
نعم يبدو ان هناك قناه
تجري خلف الكواليس هناك محادثات جرت اليوم
بين قاده في حزب الانصاف بزعامه عمران خان
وجهاز الشرطه هنا في مدينه لاهور حيث يقيم
رئيس الوزراء السابق عمران خان بالفعل صرح
بانه سوف يمثل امام المحكمه التي من
المقرر ان تعقد جلستها يوم السبت المقبل
لكن حتى الان الاليه التي سيمثل بها عمران
خان ليست واضحه المحادثات لا تزال جاريه
من المتوقع ان يكون هناك جوله اخرى من
المحادثات بين شرطه اقليم البنجاب او شرطه
مدينه لاهورو ورئيس وزراء السابق ايضا
هناك جلسه ايضا لمحكمه لاهور العليا من
المقرر ان تستانف النظر في الطلب الذي
قدمه حزب الانصاف لوقف
العمل
باجراءات اعتقال رئيس الوزراء السابق هناك
ايضا تصريح يمكن ان نعتبره ايجابي لوزير
الداخليه رانا سناء الله الذي قال ان
السلطات تفضل عدم اللجوء الى اعتقال عمران
خان من اجل مثوله امام القضاء اضافه الى
ذلك كان هناك تصريحات ايجابيه من رئيس
الوزراء
شهباز الشريف الذي قال بانه يدعو كافه
الاطراف السياسيه في باكستان للحوار بما
في ذلك حزب الانصاف بزعامه عمران خان من
اجل حل التحديات او المشاكل الاقتصاديه
والسياسيه التي تواجهها البلاد على السياق
كان هناك ايضا تصريحات من رئيس الوزراء
السابق نعم عبد الرحمن يعني مقابل هذه
الايجابيات التي تتحدث عنها عمران خان
بالساعات الماضيه اعلن بان هناك تامر من
قبل الجيش والحكومه عليه لسجنه قبل
الانتخابات خوفا من نتائج الانتخابات كيف
يعني السلطه السياسيه هناك هذه التصريحات
يعني يصفه خصومه السياسيون بانه
الرجل الذي يتغير او يغير من تصريحاته في
كل مره هذه التصريحات لا شك نعم هو هذه
ليس المره الاولى التي قال فيها رئيس
وزراء السابق عمران خان او التهاب بانها
تسعى لاختطافه وقتله
سبق ان نتحدث بهذا بهذا المعنى في عده
مناسبات لكن حديثه اليوم الحديث
الاحدث لنقل او تصريحه الاحدث بانه مستعد
للحوار مع كافه الاطراف من اجل مصلحه
البلاد
ومن اجل الحفاظ على الديمقراطيه في البلاد
وانه مستعد لتقديم تضحيات من اجل ذلك
وبالتالي سننتظر غدا لنرى ماذا سيجري يعني
الاطار القانوني والسياسي لهذه القضيه
شكرا لك عبد الرحمن المزيني مراسل العربيه
حدثنا منه
[موسيقى]
افادت وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه بمقتل اربعه
فلسطينيين واصابه 23 اخرين بينهم اربعه في
حاله خطيره وذلك برصاص القوات الاسرائيليه
التي اقتحمت مدينه جنين شمال الضفه
الغربيه وقالت وكاله الانباء الفلسطينيه
ان قوه خاصه من الجيش الاسرائيلي دخلت الى
وسط المدينه وبدات باطلاق الرصاص الحي
تجاه المواطنين ومنازلهم
[موسيقى]
تشهد اسرائيل يوم تعبئه جديده احتجاجا على
مشروع تغيير النظام القضائي غداه تقديم
الرئيس الاسرائيلي مشروع تسويه عرضته
الحكومه على الفور ويحافظ مشروع الرئيس
على طرح الحكومي بحد قدره المحكمه العليا
على الغاء قوانين اساسيه لكنه يقترح
تعديلات على النقاط المثيره للجدل في
قانون النظام القضائي ويعتبر معارضون
مشروع تغيير النظام القضائي انه يمنح
السياسيين مزيدا من السلطه على حساب
القضاء
[موسيقى]
الى ملف تيك توك حيث وضعت الاداره
الامريكيه باي دانس الصينيه الشركه الام
لتيك توك بين خيارين فاما بيع التطبيق
الواسع الانتشار في العالم او مواجهه
الحظر الكامل في الولايات المتحده وجاء
هذا الانذار النهائي لتيك توك من قبل
الوكاله الامريكيه المكلفه بتقييم المخاطر
التي تمثلها الاستثمارات الاجنبيه على
الامن القومي بحسب ما نقلت صحيفه في
المقابل يدعي تيك توك الذي لديه مليون
اكثر من 100 مليون مستخدم في الولايات
المتحده ان بيانات المستخدمين محميه كما
ينفي باستمرار مشاركه بياناته مع الحكومه
الصينيه
في المقابل قال المدير التنفيذي لتيك توك
بان عمليه بيع تيك توك لن تحل مخاوف الامن
القومي الامريكي من شركه باي دانس الصينيه
الملكه للتطبيق وفقا لصحيفه وصريت الرئيس
التنفيذى على مطالب اداره بايدن اكد ان
سحب الشركه من اصحابها الصينيين لن توفر
حمايه اكثر من الخطه التي وضعتها تيك توك
والتي تتضمن الاستعانه بشريك امريكي في
الشركه الاداره الامريكيه كانت قد عبرت عن
مخاوفها من محتوى التطبيق على الامن
القومي وطالبت بتغيير ملكيه الشركه او حظر
التطبيق في الولايات المتحده
من تيك توك الى جوجل التي قالت بان موجه
الهجمات السيبرانيه الصينيه التي تضرب
الولايات المتحده والشبكات الخاصه تمثل
مستوى جديد من البراعه والتطور لدى الصين
وانه من الصعب التحقق من طريقه الهجوم
الجديده اضافه الى ان التقنيات المضاده
حاليا يصعب عليها اكتشاف هذه الاختراقات
[موسيقى]
لا يزال استئناف الدراسه في شمال سوريا
حلما بعيد المنال بعد زلزال فبراير المدمر
تسبب تصدع جدران المدارس الى حد يستوجب
هدم بعضها الى تحول الكثير منها الى مراكز
ايواء وبلغ عدد المدارس المتصدعه في
جنديرس وحدها اثنتين وعشرين وتحتاج الى
ترميم حتى يتسنى استئناف الدراسه بها كما
يخشى اولياء الامور من وتلاميذ العوده الى
المدارس خوفا طبعا من انهيار هذه المدارس
[موسيقى]
تعرضت منطقه جنديرس لزلزال مدمر كان هناك
22 مدرسه تعرضوا للتصدعات كامله وهناك
مدرسه بحاجه لازاله كامله كان هناك ايضا
طلاب شهداء ومعلمين شهداء 25 معلم شهيد
و25 جريح وما يقارب ب 500 ل 600 طالب
متوفين
[موسيقى]
عندي ثلاث بنات وحده بكالوريا وهي انقطعت
على المدرسه وما بنعرف شلون بدها تقدم
شلون بدها تدرس والثانيه الحادي عشر
والثالثه التاسع ومن وقتها لهلا الولاد
كلهم مقطوعين على المدارس
[موسيقى]
ختام التاسعه مشاهدينا مع العلوم
حديثنا امريكي عن هجوم اوكرانيا مضاد في
الربيع وبولندا توفي بوعود ارسال
المقاتلات الجويه الى
هذه هي الحاله الوحيده التي يمكن عندها ان
يكون هناك لقاء بيني وبينه ارجوك بعد
لقائه بوتين الاسد يتحدث عن اللقاء مع
اردوغان قد يكون اليوم او غدا لكن اذا
استوفيت الشروط اولا
ونتطلع وزير خارجيه السعوديه بان ينعكس
الاتفاق على ايران ايجابا على دول المنطقه
يستعين بالدستور لتمرير قانون التقاعد
والمعارضه تدعو للانتقام عبر سحب الثقه من
الحكومه
مشاهدينا الى هنا اتي الى ختام التاسعه
لكن اخبار العربيه مستمره كما كل ليله
والان الى 360 مع الزميل صهيب شراير صهيب
ماذا لديك مساء الخير مساء الخير ليال
سنبدا من قصه مخزون اليورانيوم الليبي
التي على ما يبدو عثر عليها على الحدود مع
تشاد هناك مجموعه تشاديه كانت تعتقد انها
براميل للاسلحه والذخيره ولكن تركتها على
الحدود عندما لم تجد تلك الاسلحه
الحمد لله
ولكن ما يزال هناك خطر الاشعاع لا يجب
الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه عليها ان
تتحقق انه ليس هناك لا اشعاع في تلك
المنطقه تفضل شكرا
لك